- [Kelly] I am so happy, you're hilarious.
- [Abby] Oh, Thank you.
- And, I mean, super talented actor.
I always love comedians when they act,
Y'all can go so dark or you like heavy
or you can go really light and funny,
It's awesome to watch you.
- Yeah, I feel like
comedy, you have to be able
to really act and sell it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Because, it's a lot.
- Alright, well, do you have any plans
for Valentine's Day?
Are you one of those
people that goes all out?
- We do, we definitely eat
a lot together, always.
- [Kelly] That's like
a day that ends in Y.
- Yeah, We'll just
binge and drink, we're..
- [Justin] What are you drinking?
- Just wine.
- Okay, alright.
- [Kelly] Red girl,
white girl? Just curious.
- [Abby] Red.
- Nice, me too, Pinot Noir.
- Pinot Noir, yeah.
- I heard something about you though,
that you've always wanted
to be a mom, right?
- Yes, and we are doing
IVF right now actually.
(crowd cheers)
Thank you.
- It sounds like just a process
cause so many people go through it now,
it sounds like a process,
but it's kind of hardcore,
I've had friends go through that.
- Yeah, so this Valentine's day,
I'll be getting shots in my butt.
(laughs loudly)
- Hormones.
- But my husband is very romantic.
Yes hormones, but the
hormones are very intense
and you know, so many people,
they go through this.
- [Kelly] So many.
- And, you know, we don't
talk about it enough,
I think as women, and just,
we need to raise more understanding
and awareness behind it.
- [Kelly] And I'm glad,
that's why I was so happy
you wanted to talk about this today,
because I have friends
that went through it,
and I mean, went through
some serious depression,
felt shame, was like,
"What is wrong with me?",
like tried everything under the sun
and sometimes it just doesn't happen
and you just need science
to kind of help move it along.
- Yeah and it's actually,
it's such a miracle what they can do,
like that's a miracle in of itself.
- [Kelly] Agreed.
Did you always picture
yourself being a mom?
- Yeah, definitely.
- You're the baby of the family
and you always wanted kids?
We're like opposite humans.
- No, I'm the older sister.
- [Kelly] Oh, you're the
older, that makes sense.
- [Abby] But I had a little baby carriage
that I would, you know, and a baby doll.
- [Kelly] Oh, that was my sister,
and then she would curl my hair
and accidentally burn me, it was fine.
But you're...
- Yeah, I cut my sister's bangs a lot.
- Yeah, that's what my sister would do.
So your dad is comedian Chris Elliot,
was that intimidating for your husband
to like meet the fam?
- [Abby] Oh, yeah for sure.
- [Kelly] Cause he's hilarious.
- [Abby] Yeah, there was a hazing period
for a while with Billy.
- A hazing period? Oh, tell us.
(laughs loudly)
- Yeah, with my husband
coming into the family.
We do this thing in our family
called the Ice Bucket Challenge,
but it's not the one for charity,
it's not the good one,
it's just to sober us up
when we've been drinking too much.
(laughs loudly)
So what we do is, we all stick our head in
like a bucket of ice
to see who can last the longest in there,
and then whoever does, wins.
- I would totally do this.
- So my husband came to a wedding,
actually it was the first time
I was introducing him to my parents and..
- [Kelly] The first time you introduced
your boyfriend to your
parents was at a wedding?
- Yeah, my cousin's wedding.
- [Kelly] That is bold.
- Yeah.
- [Justin] I like it.
- And he was really
confident and you know,
and he has these like runner's lungs,
and he was underwater
for a solid two minutes,
trying to impress my family.
- [Kelly] He's gonna die
trying to impress your dad.
- Yeah.
- [Justin] Ice cold water?
- Ice cold water, yeah.
- That's great, that's commitment,
You knew right then didn't you?
- I did, he was the one, he beat my dad.
- [Kelly] He's committed
and he wants to win.
I like it, I would be
attracted to that too.
(laughs loudly)
But tell us about your
new show though, Indebted.
- Indebted, it is about baby boomers,
played by Fran Drescher and Steven Weber,
who lose all their money and go broke,
and they have to move in
with their young son and his family,
and I play the wife of the son.
- [Kelly] Whose super excited.
- Whose super excited
to have her in-laws move in.
And yeah, it's a lot.
So my character is kinda caught
in the middle of this
crazy new family dynamic
that's happening in her house,
and it's a really fun,
we have such a great time.
- [Kelly] I love personally,
both of your shows I think represent
like actual real
conversations that happen,
be it funny or serious,
and I think that's so important,
it's fun to watch
and know that you're not abnormal,
that so many families go through
all of those experiences and emotions.
- [Abby] Totally, and the
show really dives into,
you know, what it's like to be a boomer
who doesn't know how to use technology
and then we're the millennials
who are like, "Uh.",
but we're also learning from them,
so we both kind of learn from each other
and my character kinda ends up
liking having them in the house.
- That's the only part
that's not real life.
I'm just kidding.
(laughs loudly)
No, so here's my question to you,
so you do Meryl Streep
impersonations, correct?
So I was thinking like
in prep for when pigs fly
and she actually comes on my show,
could you show me the impression?
Could you show us?
- Yeah, lose your eyes, just picture her.
- Okay.
- [Abby] She's here.
- Yeah, she's here.
(laughs loudly)
- [Abby] Kelly, you don't
want me on your show,
No,
I couldn't.
(laughs loudly)
Come on.
(audience applauds)
- I haven't done it in awhile.
- That's unbelievable.
- And also, I've heard you,
I've hear you before I was crying,
I was laughing so hard,
because every picture I
do see of Meryl Streep,
she has the like most badass glasses on,
they've got to be like a thousand dollars,
they're so cute.
- [Abby] Yeah and they're so,
like on the tip of her..
- [Kelly] Yes, but with
the glasses it was funny.
You're so awesome, I love
you, you're so funny.
So we'll put this on our Meryl Instapage,
people, you're welcome.
So would y'all ever,
or would you ever, cause I
know you were on SNL for years,
would you ever host SNL, Justin?
- That would be like bucket
list for me honestly.
Yeah, that would..
- You have too.
- [Kelly] You would be so great in it.
- [Abby] Yeah, you would be so good.
- I could retire after that.
- [Kelly] I could retire, like mic drop.
Oh my gosh, okay,
well, do you want to
practice and maybe take a..
- [Abby] Yeah, I feel like cue cards
are the one thing that
you have to get used to.
- [Kelly] They do that a lot,
cause I have done a couple things.
- [Justin] We don't use cue cards,
they're like, you can practice.
- You definitely don't use cue cards,
but yeah, it's like an
art form in and of itself.
- You should practice with cue cards,
We have cue cards,
do you want to take us to break?
- Let's take you to break.
- You know what, challenge accepted,
here he goes.
- [Justin] Justin reads cards.
(everyone laughs)
Go to Justin, smile to camera 3.
Indebted premieres February 6th on N.B.C.
She needs practice flipping the cards.
- [Kelly] She doesn't know..
- When we come back,
we're getting our lobster roll on.
I'm crushing this but..
Yeah, you do not want to miss this
You don't want to miss this,
standby Camera 3, clap us out.